[Music]
The third point is that the reality of the
risk is camouflaged at all levels,
right? Banks have
very significant internal losses that they don't
show, central banks do
n't demand transparency, the
bodies responsible for conducting audits
say even less, and the
general management speaks in every
language. So if we take the
remarks that have just been made and
this very characteristic context of lack of
information, a fierce desire on the part of the
leaders to continue making
fortunes, a lack of control, and
general hypocrisy, we see that we
are in a risky environment with
players
who will do things contrary to
the general interest.
[Music]